hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
uh we're back to uh reviewing a
controversial uh
product uh premium uh speaker cable
uh it's from a company called morrow sp3
about the model number is sp3 company's
name is morro
audio and the version i have is this uh
cable as you can see also in the review
it's an eight foot cable
uh it's in the by wire configuration so
you got
one pair at the amplifier end and then
you can split it and drive the tweeter
and the woofer with
two separate wires um the cable itself
is actually quite flexible is i don't
know what's inside this uh
um we woven uh
jacket but whatever it is is much more
flexible than typical
high-end speaker cables they tend to be
stiff like these are but what's in here
is is soft and from that point of view
it also doesn't weigh a ton
uh on that which i appreciate it seems
like a lot of the high-end companies
want to sell by weight
and dimensions and they make these
garden hose
speaker cables hoping that the customers
are swayed by that as uh
premium cables go this is actually quite
reasonable in price
it's 149 for the base cable and then you
can specify what connectors and
uh whether you want to buy wire or not
if you add all that up is 187 dollars
but they seem to have a sale
of 38 percent right now which gets it
back down to
145 or so so in grand scheme of things
this is not
expensive uh if you were to sit at home
and make cables for somebody
uh for 150 dollars there's a lot of work
involved in in mucking with this thing
so
i think it's a very tedious job and
you'd be lucky to make a lot more than
minimum wage so
um they must make their money from their
cables from higher up in the line at the
rate i like the quality of the
connectors at the end
they made it quite well and and tight
without being exceedingly uh stiff
into both my measurement system and also
real amplifier and speakers that i
connected it to
excuse me um typical of cable company
uh marketing material if you look up uh
what they say is the proprietary
technology
uh it says removes major distortion
that's common in
most other cable designs of course uh
they never show any measurements of
their cable or any other one so
uh it's up to us now to go and evaluate
that so
the easiest way for me to test the cable
and nothing but
the cable is to hook it up directly to
my audi precision analyzer my audio
precision analyzer
has a set of banana jacks uh they're
used for
differential uh measurements so you
could just hook them up and then use
them
use whatever wire you want and so it
made it quite nicely to these
cables it has it both for input and
output
the drawback is that the output
impedance is 40 ohms and the input speed
impedance by default is 200 kilo ohms um
typical amplifier has an output in b
impedance well under
was one ohm and your speakers are
you know could be anywhere from four ohm
to 40 50 ohms
so from that point of view it is not a
one-to-one replication of how a speaker
cable would be used
in a sense i'm testing the spk cable as
if it's interconnect
which is a more stringent test because
now noise and things like that can get
into the cable and it's at eight foot
length with no shielding
it could potentially upset the
measurements so there's some pros and
cons in this testing but i'll address
this when we get closer to the end
so i went ahead and connected the input
to output my audio precision analyzer is
is quite capable so i can dial up the
output to
20 volts so simulating an amplifier
producing probably around 50 watts or so
into 8 ohms and when i do that
it's basically there's nothing there to
see in that the cyanide is 122 db
which is world-class for dax amplifiers
can't
get this close and and this
basically what it's doing is showing the
the as good as the analyzer itself can
measure itself
so the wire when i i can bypass it and
analyze it where
internal short occurs with the relay the
two were the same so
this wire had the same performance for
good or bad that was you know the same
as what the little internal connection
is into the
analyzer you see two channels in here by
the way because i went from one input to
two
uh one output to two inputs because it's
by wire and we're measuring both
and we see that it makes no difference
that the uh
that the outputs are separated as it
should be
uh on this thing now the key is is how
well
uh you know this cable does compare to
uh you know generic cable and for
generic cable uh excuse me let me uh
dig it up uh in here i forgot to
find it before the review and
it has ah here we go i was gonna say it
has disappeared on me but uh
i found it i grabbed some
really old uh zip cord speaker cable i
have
uh this is probably 30 to 40 year old
cable
i don't throw away stuff like this as
long as it's not rotting
and i reached in my attic and i found
this this cables and it wasn't
terminated and i've run out of
you know banana plugs and just grab
whatever i could a couple of these
uh really semi nasty uh banana ones
chinese ones from amazon and a couple of
better quality ones
uh on this thing so they're just
terminated not even the same at each end
and the
wire is roughly the same length as the
other one about eight foot or so
uh you can see it's kind of gnarly and
and stiff and uh
it's thin gauge is quite stiff
compared to the other cable and so let's
see how bad this one is uh
compared to uh our premium cable that we
just test this is probably by the way
five dollars worth of material if that
we see that now there's only one channel
here because i'm just going from one one
input to one output
uh around this is slightly different
time so the exact number is a little bit
different
uh you know analyzer is not perfect and
depending on time and temperature it it
varies just a bit but we can see the
sign at is 121.6 db
and it was 121.6 db before uh
the distortion is that in minus 150
decibels
and before was maybe 145 with the other
cable but again these are just run to
run variations
it shows that the crusty old 30 40 year
old cable is able to pass through
this 20 volt signal with just
vanishingly small
distortion noise uh our threshold of
hearing for
anything any tone any sounds about 115
100
minus 115 here and we can see that we
were able to with both of these cables
far exceed a threshold of
hearing for a human
next thing i did was that i ran a
frequency response test and not just an
ordinary frequency response that stops
at 20 kilohertz but i've actually gone
to 200 killers
again my audi precision analyzer is
quite capable and is able to
measure way past the audible band so you
can see this this thing it just
looks very very flat there's a little
bit of wiggle in it but look at this
scale
the scale vertically is only one db up
one db
down typically when i run a frequency
response test this is minus five
and the other on the other side is plus
five i've zoomed
way in ten to one and you still can't
see
any variation the 200 killers between
the
this uh sp3 morrow audio sp3 cable and
my generic crusty 5
cable and uh but again this is you know
treating it
like an interconnect and there may be
some effects when the impedance has
changed
but uh uh here by the way we're sweeping
at all frequencies
from 10 hertz all the way up to 200
kilos so it's not a one
tone and we're measuring all frequencies
we're measuring ultra
ultra uh sonic frequencies what this
tells us is that the tonality can't
change
because tonality is determined by
frequency response
and that's not changing so somebody says
it's louder or i hear more bass
and more mids or whatever that's just
not true yeah the level hasn't changed
and the tonality has not changed
now back to people making excuses for
these things they say well
sine wave is you know this simple thing
they think it's a static signal but it's
actually not a static signal a sine wave
goes up and down from minus
you know 27 volts peak to peak or so
whatever that comes out to be
and uh it's certainly not one number and
one voltage so we're actually running
through a full set of
voltages so there's nothing static about
a sine wave
on that but hey we can make more complex
waveforms
and here i've taken our standard
multi-tone test which is 32 tones all
with different phases
combined and if you look at that in the
time domain
as i've shown in other videos is quite
random and complex you would think it's
music indeed if you
uh play this it sounds like an organ uh
playing it feels like it sounds like
many of the notes
you know your organ where you put your
hand down on many keys at once and
that's what it sounds like so
in ways music like is certainly a lot
more complex from
compared to music because its tones in
high frequency are full amplitude
whereas typical music this would drop
like a rock over here so we're stressing
the cable and the systems a lot more
um i went ahead and tested the generic
cable
the morrow sp3 and the analyzer itself
on all three cases
the distortion and noise are identical
they all land on top of each other and
the colors actually mix in you can't see
it
um our distortion is down
at 21 to 22 bits uh it's about a minus
120
minus 125 to minus 130
remember our threshold of hearing is
minus 115
so we're at 15 to 20 db better than that
as far as distortion
so whatever distortion the generic
cables creating which the company said
was a problem
is below the distortion floor of the
audio precision analyzer which in
turn is 20 30 db better
than uh than our hearing and that's
basically a hundred to a thousand times
better than our hearing so
it the analyzer is quite sensitive in
that manner
on this thing and uh we can also run a
distortion plus noise sweep
uh where we vary the frequency and see
if we have any distortion and noise and
when i do that
again we see that there's just no
difference both cables just land on top
of each other and there's just no way
to distinguish them from each other
they're just extremely clean minus
115-116
this is testing harmonic structure all
the way up to 90
kilohertz so four and a half times the
audible band
to compute the harmonic structure of 20
kilohertz and
again just not a hair out of place it
just
there's no difference there but i knew
if i just stopped here people will say
well this doesn't look like an amplifier
test and a speaker test because there's
no speaker involved and there's no
amplifier involved and impedances are
different
so i figured i'd do a more clever test
in that i took this purify amplifier
that i have this
state-of-the-art amplifier and
used that to amplify the output of my
audio precision analyzer
and that gets connected to a clip
speaker that you can't see that's behind
me i put the clutch speaker on a
desk so that it's not too loud although
it has a port in the back so
it was still whistling pretty loud from
the back so i cover the port also
because we don't care about what the
speaker is producing
we want to measure the effect of a cable
and
so if i did nothing this would just pump
out test stones into the amplifier and
the amplifier produces
this sends the signal to a speaker and
the tones would play
but instead of just measuring that i
went ahead and
hooked up channel one and channel two of
my analyzer
in a special way that the channel one is
measuring
what signal we have at the beginning of
the speaker cable
and the channel two is measuring what's
at the end of the speaker cable
then using uh simple math i can tell
they
analyze their software to just subtract
one from the other
so whatever shows up is basically the
losses or distortions or the noise that
gets added or
it's not subtracted but if it were
subtracted anything that's different
different between these two will show up
so the effect is basically just the
cable and nothing but the cable
i'm not measuring the amplifier which
has its own distortions and noise and
i'm not measuring the speaker itself
which has its own distortion noise
i'm strictly measuring the cable in
between now the conditions are the way
the cable gets used
the load is on the right side it's a
real speaker the load on the left is an
amplifier it's a switching amplifier so
it has high frequency harmonics and so
forth
it's it's uh harsher if you will on a
cable because it produces more than just
the audible band
so now around a sweep instead of just
one tone is 20
hertz to 20 kilohertz and this is what
the difference
looks like now don't worry about the
shape of this graph
in that the losses seem to increase as
you go to higher frequencies
there are testing errors due to the
cables i'm
using and so forth so all we care about
in here is
the difference between a generic cable
and the
expensive cable higher end cable and
i've got both of those plotted
and you can barely see them separated
here
and you might say okay so there is some
difference
in here no there isn't if you look at
the scale in here
this is in decibel the lower scale is
.015 db
minus 0.15 and the
plus side is 0.006 so
if you add up figure this out the entire
scale from bottom to the top is 1 10
of a db not 1 db 0.1 tp
and within that we have this tiny tiny
tiny change so
it just gets lost on that
we can actually plot the difference
between these two curves rather than
looking at them as an absolute
and this is what the difference between
the two cables are and look at the
number of zeros and decimal places in
here
is point zero zero zero six
db difference between the two um
so it just it's an absurdity
on top of absurdity level difference but
it shows you how accurate our
instrumentation is we're able to measure
things
as if you know um i'll turn on the light
and your light dims you know 1000 miles
away
we can measure almost effects that small
uh with our instrumentation but no
matter what we do
we just can't tease out any difference
between these cables they're just
made to pass through the signal and
you know even though we can measure some
tiny differences your hearing is just
so much worse than this that it's just
not even in
within the realm of possibility to
believe
that this cable makes a difference so
i'd say the conclusions are pretty
strong uh
in that you know we're measuring the
cable we're
instrumenting at different ways and in
every way
they're transparent which is good news
so unlike some cables that go
try to have active components in them or
too much capacitance or inductance where
they may
cause issues this capability is benign
and then it doesn't do
anything but it also has no benefit
so if you're buying this cable and you
already had a perfectly working
zip cord that you were happy with when i
said zip cord by the way i mean the
standard lamp chords
or the excuse me garden variety chords
there's no reason to replace with
something like this
unless you like the look of it unless
you like the feel of it if this
wires are exposed then you like to have
this exposed and you know you have a
nice looking system and
this is like jewelry for for your
equipment
uh you're welcome to get it i actually
don't have anything against this company
as i mentioned 150 to build you this is
reasonable
it has good feel and qualities i wish
the company would just go through their
website and erase everything to do
with all these claims of fidelity and
distortion all that
and just said look the cables are cables
but we make them to length
we terminate them exactly what you want
we make them look
nice you can have by wire single wire
any ending you want
and that makes tidy and pretty behind
your equipment the connectors are better
quality so they're not likely to pop
out come loose on their own and i think
you can still sell
cables for 150 and there'll be a lot of
takers including a lot of people
in our world uh even i make well
i don't have the need but if i did i
wouldn't mind spending this kind of
money
now if it were thousands of dollars that
would be different ball game so
bottom line feel free to buy the cable i
don't think they're ripping people off
on
on this cable at least at these prices
but certainly the marketing claims are
wrong and i wish they would
stop just repeating what others do and
and promote stuff like this
okay thanks for watching and
see you in a future video bye